before you go any further
[Music]
multiverse of madness
doctor strange cast the smell to get
peter parker out of hell now we're
entering the multiverse of madness
colors colors everywhere tackle
america shopping
all right guys we're gonna watch this
one division quick limitation okay okay
that's the last one easter eggs and
breakdown from new rock stars today for
that amazing trailer
let's watch this hit that like button if
you're here welcome back to new
rockstars i'm eric voss and this is a
breakdown of the latest trailer for
marvel's doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness which assures us i
will always be there old friend dancer
mate we are getting an mcu illuminati
lineup including patrick stewart charles
xavier what is this movie i gotta admit
i've outdone myself on this one folks
analyzing this trailer you're looking
exhausted eric i don't think everyone
else is
and uh yeah i'm also gonna include some
stuff in the tv spot version of the
trailer and clues in the official poster
let's get started the whole package is
here every night
tonight the same dream
so the trailer opens in strange's
nightmare a frightening hellscape
covered in bones and skulls dead trees
bent askew and in front of him a
representation of the sanctum sanctorum
melting into inky nothingness like the
other new york buildings we saw in the
first trailer
inc melting of reality and what if
episode four except that this isn't
exactly strange's sanctum it's
significantly thinner than we last saw
in spider-man no way home and it is one
floor taller the effect is a more gaunt
structure like a croaky haunted hotel
what fat shaming
is now a withering skeleton of itself
and notice in the sky is a glowing red
eye reminding us of course of the red
edges of wanda maximoff's hex
this whole nightmare could be being
projected into strange's mind by the
scarlet witch since the commercials in
wanovision were confirmed to be messages
from strange to wanda these two share a
psychic link now this strange has a
patch of blue sewn into the cloak of
levitation an inverse of the red patch
on blue of defender stream who saves
america chavez in a second blue versus
red seems to be an important point of
contrast in this film rooster team
shifted from his normal red tones to
blue tone along with a lot of the
settings in this to signal passivity all
do what you're saying wanda max mock's
red chaos and violence that's
interesting you could actually interpret
the colors of blue and red many
different ways blue often being
associated with like protector brad
being like fire and passionate and then
when you think about the two's
motivations of what they represent in
this movie at least from what the
trailers have been leading on i feel
like thematically that is a good
production design choice for what
they're doing because i'm deep as [ __ ]
dude that was so impressive so deep now
on the other side of the sanctum doors
there's a reverse shot of strange's
entrance from the first trailer now we
see how the stormy sea has claimed the
whole sanctum structure saved for the
central staircase which now extends up
and up and up and in nowhere like a
trick luring one to heaven except it's
not it goes into this hellish red eye
base of the staircase these weren't
there the pastimes we saw the sanctum
now these two statues one male one
female both bearing torches may be
representing the maximoff twins then a
team shutters on the ground behind it
looks like the wheel of an old
wheelchair now this isn't exactly the
wheelchair professor x from the x-men
films but i suspect a lot is going to be
changing for whatever cameos show up in
this film then america chavez gets
strung up in front of a star portal
which if you look closely it opens up to
endless more star points within that
portal that's american damn power to
kick open these star-shaped portals we
might actually be seeing the origin of
her powers right here we actually saw
the same setting in the first trailer i
think it is her home reality the utopian
parallel in the comics the utopian
parallel faces destruction from black
holes so her mothers sacrificed
themselves their particles dispersing
throughout the multiverse and the
creature attacking her here maybe go
with me on this the demiurge who is the
embodiment of earth's sentient life in
the comics the original source of her
powers and we should mention is one
final form of billy kaplan wiccan wanda
maximoff's son which could be how this
film ties the fate of wanda and her sons
to that of america chavez then again the
demiurge hasn't really been shown to be
this hostile and demonic actually
another possibility here this entity's
ribbony appearance like glowing
electrical tape could connect to
strange's spell the crimson bands of
citrax which are used to restrain thanos
infinity war which could make this fella
maybe citrac himself now the tv shot
actually showed in this moment an
alternate defender doctor strange hair
tied back in a ponytail with stripes
saving american shapes yeah yeah
it's like a three-dimensional version of
strange's normal flat eldritch magic to
hold off the entity which would then
lead to the scene in this trailer of
that same ponytail doctor strange
tumbling through a star portal a shot
that flips upside down to find us back
with our doctor strange in bed but is it
our doctor strange because his hands are
fully healed when in past films
strange's hands are always meant to be
forever scarred and weak there's an ipad
left open on his bed coffee filters into
test tubes on his nightstand strange
said in this part of the trailer that he
has the same dream every night hell
sanctum his alternate self saving a kid
and then the nightmare begins so the
nightmare might be this reality that he
wakes up into a reality where he never
became a sorcerer he never injured his
hands and really just aged into a lonely
douchebag falling asleep with its
pornhub tab still open wow that would be
pretty nuts if actually this movie
manages to mess with us on a perspective
level we think we're watching our doctor
strange this whole time and then we end
up finding out like oh no what if they
introduced the strange that we're
accompanying with throughout the mcu
much later on in the movie or like act
two like we have to wait a while before
we get there it looks like it would be
like the opening scene like a
nightmarish opening scene that they were
showing there yeah absolutely i mean
that would be such a boss move from a
mystery level and i feel like too with
all the you know like leaks and
speculation everybody like what are the
cameos gonna be i feel like that could
be a big asset to this movie if it could
just put us completely off our pins and
disorient us so that the actual like
nature of our main character is in
question i think that would be a really
cool mystery those demons look
terrifying they do
oh my god that's scary the nightmare
begins
they didn't do they like the previous
logos to do
now when strange says the nightmare
begins we should also acknowledge the
possibility that the demonic entity
nightmare could be the villain of this
film as this idea was floated by the
original director scott derrickson the
marvel studios title card turns purple
and has tentacles snaking across the
letters evoking the limbs of gargantos
but also one of the multi-limbed
creatures and what if which this movie
seems to be showing the live-action
versions of strange supreme poster for
this film in the lower right corner one
broken shard of glass shows this shield
of captain carter hinting that haley
atwell may start
nuts
do it then dr strange conjures these red
orbs if you look closely they are coming
from the dark hole on the floor there
that's marvelous book of the damn that
appeared on wano vision first in
agatha's possession before it was
claimed by wanda that's why the magic he
conjures is now red like wanda's chaos
magic as we saw her conjuring in that
final wanda vision scene we could be
seeing a depiction of the various
universes being connected in this movie
with dr strange trying to locate one
world in particular and in the
foreground of that shot that looks like
that is one of maximoff standing there
with him but then strange suddenly
afraid slams all this magic back into
the book as if he's trying to hide it
from the person in the room with him and
on that page you can see a triangle
perhaps the symbol of marvel's
illuminati a location he wants to hide
from wanda maximov for reasons i'll get
to later wait a second this might be
because with all the cameos that are
being teased in here because i put out a
question on twitter like what universes
do you think we're going to be going to
and some people have their own theories
that they were sharing on our social
media so i'm counting one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven two
twelve ten eleven to twelve universes
here on frame what if we're hopping in
that many universes in this movie oh
that's like the first setup for here's
everything we'll be hopping to every
scene will be in a new universe yeah if
i looks from the looks of it i mean you
could at this point have just literally
only through line be your main character
if that so strange argues that he did
what he had to do to protect our world
our world as in his actions saved his
universe at the expense of all other
universes forget the other universes
this is the american one there's an
improper advantage to undo thanos's snap
and more recently he used his magic of
the runes of cough call to basically
gaslight and warp society into a whole
bunch of plot holes mordo warned us
about this that when strange would push
the laws of reality like this the bill
comes
due
always and like strange in that what if
universe bypassing an absolute point
this strange's reality has begun to melt
the same exact way and open itself up to
interdimensional threats god i love what
you're saying because of the fact that
one of my concerns is that okay i'll be
doing a little too much for one movie
because you have to still have some type
of level of character-driven narrative
like for doctor strange not just like
wanda or supporting characters and then
the fact that this all seems to be
coming back to like everything is
indicating that it's dealing with the
consequences of what we've seen strange
do in prior movies where it was strictly
heroic stuff and now it's oh what you
did is actually you know this cacophony
of terrible cataclysmic events man oh
yeah i think that's really cool weight
to put on him that he has to solve well
it looks like here you could get a
perhaps gray greater approach to that
than like in the what if episode like
the what if episode is going what if
he's the kind of exact opposite of his
own personality now driven by this one
obsession whereas here you know it seems
like he's he's still trying to act with
the world's best interest and maybe it's
going very wrong and thematically
compliments spiderman no way home as
well what peter parker had to deal with
we see a new look at this melting from
the rooftop individual bricks breaking
off cars floating in that blizzard
headlights still shining now the melting
of the buildings here seems to merge
into these black strands reminding us of
the ancient one's dark branch timeline
that she warned bruce banner about an
endgame and here it's not just that
reality is melting great visual
continuity chaos is spinning into one
beneficiary destination
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
yeah
he was right
so we see scarlet witch once again
holding the seance in the commentary
courtyard we know that's where it is
because you can tell from the statues
behind her in the floor beneath her the
same tiling that we see beneath that
minotaur sorcerer later we get a better
look of him in this trailer this is
rantra from the comics oh you
because actually in the tv spot the
sorcerers in that courtyard raised their
shields to some floating figure overhead
i'm pretty sure that is wanda now
compared to her look at the end of wanda
vision during the seance her scarlet
witch wardrobe has evolved her sleeves
now cover her arms fully and darker
tones streak through her chest piece and
her tiara and more draping or the tips
of her fingers are black similar to
agatha's fingers when she would use dark
magic and i like this right as we hear
strange stuff somehow looks sexier
blows out from her body now in her
orchard if that is what it really is
wanda tells strange that vision had
theories about the multiverse that was
dangerous so despite vision warning
wanda she still created an alternate
reality in that westview hex and now
continues to peer through alternate
universes to find her children and yes
this peaceful orchard with sheep is
probably an illusion because later in
the trailer as wanda points out the
double standard of strange breaking the
rules and him getting to be a hero
strange is wearing the same outfit as he
is oh [ __ ]
much darker place at this moment both in
her mindset and in her literal
surroundings moving on oh what a mind
trip
i'm sorry stephen
what is any scene
so strange brings america chavez and
christine palmer to the ruins of what i
think is utopian parallel and christine
wears this sleek blue outfit and that's
because this might actually be an
alternate christine palmer whom strange
found working at illuminati hq because
the tv spot reveals christine
oh fascinating okay they're detainment
sector then mordo or perhaps
that might actually be sorcerer supreme
from his native reality detain strength
using these nifty looking handcuffs i
love the design of these because it's a
mix of analog sorcerer machinery with
runes engraved into that spinning lock
in the middle but overall they have this
chunky silver chrome of something more
futuristic something that might be
connected to the vibranium tech of these
ultron sentries ultron centuries who
escort dr strange in this awesome
location that looks like a supreme court
hall of justice you see four kneeling
winged statues and then a warrior with a
sword in a ring the way a certain
multiverse award captain carter emerged
from a circular portal with her sword in
hand now this whole interior founded the
illuminati
staircases the classic columns is
actually the interior of the british
museum in london a place i've been to
many times i love the british museum
it's famous for watching the rosetta
stone one of the earliest artifacts that
anthropologists have used to translate
and decode cross-reference old languages
which is super fitting for charles
xavier to model his multiversal nexus
point on such a cultural touchstone now
assuming this is illuminati hq i find it
fascinating the parallels between this
and the citadel of he who remains
which also had a lit tower inner columns
and four statues in its central chamber
one of which was mysteriously destroyed
never got an answer to what that was all
about there was someone on twitter who
pointed out to me the way how like when
there was a poster reveal for endgame
how it's
like it's spelled end game or something
like that when you look at the shapes oh
yeah yeah this spells loki
ah
okay
i i oh i can i can actually you can
actually see it yeah right uh i i don't
know if that's intentional but it's kind
of cool to think about doctor strange 2
is secretly loki season 2. what i'm
loving about this is that this is
feeling like a supernatural movie also a
sci-fi movie like a witchcraft with
sci-fi like
when did we get [ __ ] like that yeah now
there are six chairs on the illuminati
panel but we only see three members in
this trailer could kang have been a
fourth member of the illuminati who was
cast out leading to him constructing his
own crude imitation of the illuminati
citadel a citadel and a sham judicial
bureaucracy of his own run solid theory
damn that would be nuts no that's a
that's a good theory
absolutely
we should tell him the
oh baby yes one of the biggest reveals
in mcu history one that we will be
unpacking for months to come yes that
was the voice of patrick stewart
professor charles xavier in the fox
x-men films now in the marvel cinematic
universe as a member of what is almost
certain to be the illuminati now
marvel's illuminati is a secret alliance
of tony stark charles xavier reed
richards doctor strange black bolt and
namor black panther was initially gonna
be part of it but he backed out actually
in iron man 2 tony stark had a little
app on his phone labeled illuminati fun
little easter egg
still go by that name in the mcu seem to
be serving as a multiversal governing
body with representatives from across
universes by bringing fox x-men
characters into this they're building on
the metal logic from spider-man no way
home marvel studios is now adopting
formerly separate cinematic universes as
mere universes within their multiverse
and expanding to the fox x-men titles
but if patrick stewart is a
representative from a separate reality
that could limit how much of that
separate reality we actually see in this
movie and which other fox x-men cameo
just yet like ian mckellen magneto hugh
jackman wolverine maybe maybe not but
ryan reynolds deadpool very likely as he
has been long confirmed to cross over to
the mcu and now that door has been
opened i mean this could also give us
some context finally to why evan peters
was cast as wanda's brother pietro in
her hex yeah yes the show producers did
say this is just a ralph boner joke but
the logic is all in place now we never
saw ralph after wanda's hex so it could
just be as simple as wanda's ability to
warp reality might have caused her to
pull the likeness of a pietro from the
nearest adjacent universe like if tom
holland peter parker were to die in the
mcu and juan max moff wanted to create a
pocket reality where peter was alive
once more the peter in that hex might
look like andrew
if that makes sense to you evan peters
actually being pietro from his fox x-men
timeline crossing over into one division
could make an equal amount of sense but
i thought in the show it was saying that
agatha's the one who found the body that
was you a cristal possession real
brother's body is on another continent
crippled by your own self-doubt that you
believed it like the theory lines up
same time i'm also going by the dialogue
of what the show is actually saying
unless it's like an alley-oop or
something where it's like wanda pulled
him in and then she double tricked him
to think he's ralph boner but to also
then pretend he's quickstar though he's
also quick yeah it is a bit confusing
and also with xavier i'm wondering if
they are going to pull him from the
x-men animated series instead clearly
we're pulling stuff from the animated
what if series it would be cool if they
pull from the x-men animated series and
it also wouldn't undo the events of
logan charles xavier did die and that
was like patrick stewart's send-off
movie so if he's playing like a
completely different person i think if
they pull from the x-men anime show and
if he had yellow levitating ship and
deadpool's part of the illuminati i
don't know if this is the charles xavier
from the exact fox x-men timeline
whatever that was at the end of that
series because one thing that was clear
is that charles xavier died in the year
2029 in logan after it was revealed he
accidentally killed all the x-men or
most of them i think it's likelier that
this charles could be from a branch
timeline within that universe because
time travel screwed up a lot of stuff
there let's be honest he actually could
be something closer to a live-action
version of the x-men 97 oh [ __ ] i'm just
saying that
perfect cross promotion for the new
series now yes there are six chairs
let's try to fill these chairs who they
belong to two of the figures are seated
and one walks in with a cane so i'm
wondering if this could be charles who
in this form has found his ability to
walk once more now the seated finger but
he rose
fitting suit that you could say looks a
lot like the vibranium armor of black
panther and yes this illuminati lineup
may include a new actor playing a
variant t'challa however i think this
particular figure just looks a bit more
slender in the arms like reed richards
but that would also make it less likely
to be john krasinski yeah let's be
honest he's jacked ryan let's slide over
to that other seated bring your back
y'all girlfriend could this be sorcerer
supreme morto or all reality photon or
spectrum monica rambo or were those
ultron centuries a clue that one member
of this panel is actually ultron
infinity from what if or that
theseus white vision from one division
but my favorite version of this would be
this could be a reality in which tony
stark's ultron protocol actually
succeeded instead of turning on him
which led to him being able to evolve
into the superior iron man one played by
tom
i mean we've heard this speculation for
years and now it just seems all possible
doesn't it let's focus on what charles
actually says here we should tell him
the truth what truth the truth that
strange maybe didn't do anything wrong
or that him becoming a sorcerer was a
mistake or that all of this is just some
kang exposed sham organization perhaps
but i think the truth here is about mcu
that we have loved all these years is
not the core reality of this multiverse
that instead we have actually been
living in an incomplete post-house of
him reality where mutants have been
erased this whole time we just didn't
see it as anything wrong and now
before you go any further
i did a whole video where i was like
that did this whole theory about it like
a couple weeks ago
what if the mcu timeline we've been
watching for the last 13 years
no more mutants has already happened if
i'm anywhere near the same page as you
eric i am flipping out right now you are
winning literally said this exact thing
you are winning this video
that's like three solid theories in a
row just keep going no no you burned it
i mean i don't know but we gotta wait
today i might be like jumping the shark
here okay some real bonkers [ __ ] here
doctor strange and american chavez fall
through a reality that freaking dinosaur
have you ever noticed that
king kong right now an animated cartoon
reality wow
this can actually be how the animated
captain carter gets roped into this then
strange and murdered holy [ __ ] keep her
animated the whole movie the mix of
draxes reality stone hit infinity war
and joe casadas art of the scarlet witch
on the house of them variant cover some
of their blocks look like stones from a
statue that's how you deserve to
actually see the rows of stephen's
individual teeth still intact in his
gums on each block
dude this movie's like space jamming new
legs
we're into the server first the marvel
servers if they're going to the animated
world that would mean every event we saw
in what if is part of its own separate
animated universe multiverse i guess and
then every animated series is part of
its own animated you know there's just
an animated side of reality wow that is
nuts looks like wanda will invade
illuminati hq and get into a huge brawl
with someone who looks like they're
going binary the way captain marvel does
but if you look at that person closely
this is a woman of color now i know some
of you think this is tom cruise with a
goatee that's just a contouring of her
cheeks tom cruise's figure is not this
womanly folks this is definitely either
michael rambo or her mother maria rambo
maria rambo's call sign was photon and
in the main mcu she died of cancer
during the blip but in one of vision
monica rambo powered up into the
superhero we assume will either be
photon or spectrum and the moment that
happened her body was split into several
alternates
as she passed through that hex wall and
i think one of those alternate selves
could be this one we are seeing now and
if you think about it monica fighting
wanda seems to be the most epic
collision considering these two were
both there for the battle of west
exactly
story-wise yeah
the tea room that we saw in the 2016
film including master hamir returning
from that film then a close-up of
marquitas gives a good look at her
wardrobe star is embroidered on her jean
jacket along with the phrase amore s
amor love is love and a flag pin
signaling some lgbtq plus representation
gargantuars throws
with an ad on the end for la llave
coffee the key with the tagline unlock a
better day and then over to the left the
phone booth has an ad for celestial tea
the magic of tea then i love this shot
strange looks up at another alternate
sanctum with a statue out front a statue
that has no facial hair though in this
new york greenery and oddly curved wind
turbines cover all the buildings and
white flowering trees line the streets
trees like the ones in wanda's orchard
so in strange's nightmare we saw the
darkest timeline here this looks like
the brightest timeline where a variant
strange has used his powers only to
better society moving on
nice
all right i really want to hear what
this is yeah i really want to hear this
part that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
okay so interesting two wandas meet each
other and this is wanda's west view
house in one division you can see two
scooters in the background belonging to
her sons billy and tommy one of their
baseball gloves on the floor there but
this place is wrecked the staircase
handrail the blusters are broken as if
there was a fight between these two
wandis and the standing one is the one
who is barefoot yacht i actually wonder
if this kneeling wanda tried to recreate
the westview hex to have her children
once more but failed and now defeated
she's letting the darker side of her
identity take over if you think about it
the last time we saw her
consciousness was split into two
conscious selves something people who
astrally project normally can't do there
was one in casual wear brewing tea and
then the other one in the scar of the
witch forum searching for her kids
actively now i'm wondering which of
those two is actually the deadlier
threat the one who's searching for her
kids or the one who's just sipping tea
not giving up can you see that shot
again striking strange's cuffs now i'm
wondering if mortar might be doing this
on purpose to freeze strange so that
strange can help them fight this
invading scarlet witch but it might be
too late because a huge explosion from
red chaos magic tears through the buddy
leading to these elaborate fireworks as
we think rainbow's form gets blasted
through that explosion then this other
sorcerer uses there's so much happening
i can't even keep up with this the tv
spot actually showed american chavez
beneath this gross underbelly and in
these close-ups so you can see how each
of its tentacle suckers are actually
barbed with teeth
then this gnarly shot of wanda aiming
red chaos magic she's at the doorway of
illuminati hq her face is bleeding like
crazy and separately she has black ink
stains on her shirt behind her in the
distance looks like one of the bells of
comartage perhaps after sacking that
location and holding her seance there
she used that to access the gateway to
this compound but why does she want to
get in here well when the camera zooms
into her eye there's a brief image of
two holding cells these are illuminati
detention cells doctor strange was
cuffed in one of these and in the teeth
who hold them
in another cell so i think the reason
wanda hasn't been able to find a reality
with their sons the reason why her
attempt to recreate west view didn't
work is that the illuminati are
detaining billy and tommy here in these
two cells and for wanda that's
especially infuriating because it's
exactly what hydra did to her and her
twin brother locking them up in adjacent
cells like in the comic house of m all
of this madness comes from a denial by
professor x and by doctor strange to
allow wanda reality with her children
and it's gonna end with wanda
drastically warping all that reality but
in this case i think a restoration of
mutants alongside avengers in the mcu
but why would they not in this storyline
why would they not allow her to have her
children i don't know because i mean if
they're just creations what would it
hurt i guess unless there is some true
mephisto connection there that we don't
know about yet that they know about it
could happen at this bed right this
juncture i feel like but actually maybe
yeah without a crap that's been included
in one movie yeah now it suddenly seems
way less far-fetched than before
oh that's interesting i really love
everything with one and i love the idea
that she's not fighting like a variant
of herself but she's fighting she's
encountering something she has also
created as well yeah she's like split
herself and the the split has become too
powerful between the two of them almost
yeah so we end with a version of doctor
strange and wong on this snowy mountain
top trying to reign in these demonic
figures these beans look like they're
actually made of the same inky texture
that the buildings and the other
surfaces are melting into as if this is
the chaos that it's all bleeding into
now the tv spot actually shows strange
facing another peak across the way with
some winged devil at the peak of it that
spot also shows a close-up of strange
whose face is rotting away looking a lot
like his zombie strange self and what if
episode 5. i point it out because the tv
spot also includes a shot of wanda
looking especially zombie-like now while
zombie strange in that episode got
devoured by ants zombie wanda survived
and she returned in the final episode so
i don't know if these are zombies as
much as they're just animated corpses
but it is insane to see their souls so
strong that they can keep their bodies
intact long after their flesh should
have expired holy [ __ ] what if one of
them is just a zombie and then one is a
reanimated corpse i mean that's
something that sam raimi would really
know how to utilize kabot dead eyes baby
what i noticed is that it looks like the
same outfit and the similar blood
splatter pattern as the shot where she's
got the magic and it zooms into her eyes
so i'm wondering yeah like is wanda
gonna somehow die and then through the
power of chaos and reanimate herself
yeah yeah because that is a good call
that's what i was thinking so especially
if that's where christine palmer is
located so yeah this could just be uh
instead of going to the marvel zombie
verse that could just be reanimated
corpses would probably make more sense
because those corpses don't seem too
smart whereas these guys seem to possess
some intelligence marvel deadites let's
do it the final shot shows this rotting
strange blocking a rift into darkness
dozens of inky skeletons trying to shove
out past him a skeleton arms fan out
behind him evoking the images of icon
pose that he formed when fighting thanos
infinity war now counteracting that
spell was the one time we saw the soul
stone being used in the mcu and i find
it interesting that strange's soul is
all he has left the film title comes
together from hundreds of pieces like
the shattering and reassembling shards
of reality in this movie but this is the
third title design we've seen it's
almost like the studio wants us to
constantly reframe the reality in which
we see this movie every time they talk
about it so folks you've gotta check out
our new so
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
after saying i want to get a fisto shirt
from it's it's freaking you guys yeah
yeah
we both call dibs on that one yeah
we'll get there's two we can yeah we can
decide who gets here guys leave your
thoughts down below we'll see you soon
thanks for watching rockstars man
subscribe to me all right bye
[Music]